Andrew and Chris have garnered a lot of
attention during this pandemic but we
are also getting to know Chris's wife
Christina and his 17 year old daughter
Bella now in our exclusive with the
Cuomo ladies we begin with Kristina's
recent kovat 19 controversy when you
talked about putting some Clorox in your
bath you maybe have gotten a little bit
of backlash my doctor prescribed a
highly diluted water and bleach bath
noting that she gave me was in any way
meant to be cure her covered Christina
wants to make it clear she did this
under her doctor's care she's not
advocating for people to do this on
their own well I was surprised to hear
people criticizing the bath the 50 year
old started showing kovin 19 symptoms 18
days after her husband Chris contracted
the virus not long after that their
fourteen-year-old son Mario also got
sick 11 year old Karolina and 17 year
old Bella remain healthy and the high
school junior stepped up to take care of
the family who is the stricter parent
you are like your real mom and dad I was
snippy er because you know I'm not used
to raising children well what does Bella
really think about fans having a Cuomo
crush on her dad and uncle it's kind of
weird to open tik-tok up and see people
calling my family members hot I'm not
gonna live videos with that
is that more like what he's like at home
or is he more like Chris Cuomo anchorman
most of the time it's like yeah it's
like dancing around just thinking you
can sing doing it real loud so everyone
hear the Cuomo's are also bringing
awareness to mental health
Chris's brother-in-law designer Kenneth
Cole launched a Mental Health Initiative
and celebs are joining in I have decided
to join a challenge called how are you
really challenged I think the point of
this challenge is to let you guys know
that you guys are not alone
communication is everything right now we
just don't have enough of it
[Music]